I really want to start with congrats on
sharper but before I get into talking
about your movie
um I think Andor is the best thing on TV
and I just want to talk just a touch
about uh your work on Andor if you don't
mind of course I definitely want to know
I mean you got to direct a number three
I believe three episodes on Android you
got to do the finale what was it like
being part of a show like that which is
so beloved by so many people well I I
mean the honest answer to that is I well
I didn't know that but I mean star was
generally being beloved by everyone just
Andor because people specifically love
Andor yeah that is listen that is great
but but obviously that's happened after
we made it but you know at the time
there wasn't really a lot of it didn't
seem like there was a lot of heat on
Andover it felt that it was slightly um
you know it was just a undercover and
that this massive show has been made in
Pinewood but that people had some how
forgotten about it and you have to bear
in mind I am not
um I am not the biggest Star Wars fan
and I I don't mean that in any sort of
um uh mean way I just mean I I from a
kid I was but I sort of I just maybe
fell out of love with her or I sort of
hadn't followed it sort of as I um in my
later years so and I and I declared that
to Tony really early on I said look Tony
I'm I if you want is this a question
about sort of
um what's been going on Star Wars
recently I I have no idea I'm a little
happily go and watch uh the last few
films but I I haven't seen them and he
was like no that's great we don't we
don't want fan service we want uh you
know I I've deliberately seen you know I
I'm aware of your work and I like your
work and I want that work in in Andor
and so
um so that that's how it came about and
I responded to his writing you know he I
I hadn't I hadn't I had went I hadn't
read anything like that for for a long
time and I sort of forgot that I
genuinely forgot that it was Star Wars
you know there were no you know there
was no lightsabers there was no Darth
Vader there was none the force it was
just really well drawn out
um narratives and great characters that
I just wanted to spend time with and
that that's as a director or me
personally that's that's what I respond
to and I guess that's where it all
started and then
when we were filming I mean you know I
just approached it to like anything else
I do you know just
you direct it I don't know I think
that's the reason why Andor is so good
is because you could it could be if you
took the Star Wars out of it it would
still be an amazing show do you know
what it we should move on to Shopper but
I just really for me it was a spy
Thriller it was a thriller and I guess
look you know you know Tony Gilroy I
mean I love born and I love my favorite
spy Thriller and I and I thought that is
I could that's what I lent into yes it
was in the Star Wars universe but it was
a spy thriller so I lent into that
um you know that that kind of tone and
mood so one of the things I really
thought was cool is that um without
spoilers each chapter of the film
essentially is its own aesthetic and I'm
curious what is it like as a director
when you obviously have to film certain
locations on the same day that are
taking place in the different chapters
on the same day when you're going for
sort of a different look like the
beginning looks almost like a romantic
New York City movie well that's I mean
the honest is preparation you know like
anything you just got to be you've got
to be a really good student you've got
to be really well prepared you've got to
have all of those conversations before
you go out and and start filming you
know with your with your sort of with
your with your crew I guess
um you know we sort of broke it down I
was I
um I remember we had this we had this
mood board in the in the design
department and it was and it sort of
went through all of the different
chapters and it was and you could and it
was like a colorway it was amazing so
the sort of first chapter were were
those kind of one car why beautiful
um kind of oranges and reds and greens
of spring and then we sort of got to the
second chapter and it was more like
tungsten and yellow and and it almost
devoid of color so those and then so on
and so on so they were you know that was
that was pretty much
um a kind of guiding principle from the
beginning throughout the chapters and
then um with the actors we had a
rehearsal process where we kind of
um well I
made the story more linear so that we
could kind of go through it in the in in
the sort of the again trying not to give
any too much away but sort of going
through it in uh in a in a in a you know
how the story would have played out and
then and then you just bottled all that
up and you you're back on set so I you
know it's funny you talk about shooting
out sequence I think on one day we shot
the beginning of the movie and on the
next day we shot the end of the movie
because the the film excuse the pun but
you know bookends beginning and end of
the film takes place in the bookstore
and so
um you know but I'm I'm used to that I'm
and I think most filmmakers are used to
that now because uh you know whether
it's on uh episodic television or you
know feature films now you know not not
it's a luxury now to shoot uh anything
in sequence you know it's just um it
certainly is a location-based movie
you're you know you you just we wouldn't
be able to achieve the ambition of this
film in the places I want to go to
racing across the whole of New York City
if we were gonna shoot it in um sequence
one of the things about this film I like
talking about editing because that's
where everything comes together but
especially with this film because of the
non-linear order like the editing is
incredibly important to this film
because you're figuring out how much you
want to give away and when so can you
sort of talk about the challenges you
ran into in the editing room maybe how
the film changed in ways you didn't
expect yeah that's a good question so I
guess well generally I I when I first
read this I embraced and love the fact
that this was sort of a non-linear
narrative and that you know it's um you
know with the structure itself sort of
Echoes the the stories tricks and turns
my long time collaborator Yan Mars and
I've worked together for I think now 10
12 years we've worked together right
from the beginning of season the crayon
and he edited the andal with me so we
have a a sort of a real understanding
and love of exactly as you're referring
to the sort of playfulness that you can
explore in editing
um one of the things we
um
you know we we the end of the movie
wasn't quite as finished as
uh when we you know in in the early
script stage and even when when we'd
finished it so uh I remember I remember
there was a day when I came into the
Cutting Room and
um uh I sort of pulled out this big
piece of paper and I sort of I wrote out
the film in linear fashion and for a
moment he started yeah yeah I was like
he's lost a plot he basically wants me
to sort of re-edit the movie and put it
back into sort of not you know linear
and and then I was like no no we've got
this is all to do with
um the last chapter and how
um I think I just seen Usual Suspects
and I and I and I wanted this idea that
there was this you know this story that
we could take from the rest of the film
that would
um
uh give us this final act that uh was
was it was there it was kind of all it
was there all along but you didn't see
it the film there was another message in
the film that we could sort of use at
the end so that's that came together
completely in The Cutting Room that sort
of Final Act
um yes we you know yes I'd shot I'd
always shot sort of bits along the way
that I knew that could form part of this
big kind of puzzle or this big jigs you
know jigsaw puzzle at the end but it
wasn't you know I wasn't really clear to
me what the kind of through line was and
that was something we definitely
discovered in the in the edit and then I
I love
um
you know uh with yeah and I love
um intercutting sequences I love
um sort of you know going with the story
and then meanwhile something happens to
hear so in the Tom chapter a lot of
those scenes that you see between Tom
and Sandra in the kitchen were actual
scenes you know there were actual proper
scenes between the two of them but we
there was a kind of there was a pacing
issue around that time
um I wanted to I wanted there to be a
kind of classical
you know for all intents purposes an
independent an indie rom-com Montage you
know and so we had that piece of music
by Curtis Harding and we started
amalgamating those scenes into kind of
more broken up moments with
um with like sort of other
um kind of non-dialock scenes that we
shot either Up on the Rooftop of
um in you know in Times Square and we
sort of you know I like to let's say we
put it in the washing machine put it all
in the washing machine we jumbled all
around and it sort of comes out with
that and that so those things definitely
were discoveries in the you know in the
in the editing process so did you end up
with a lot of deleted scenes well so
there yes there's one what do we there's
two scenes that we had to cut and one
one scene
was in that was basically about a sort
of Max and Madeline origin story
and we shot it in Washington Square Park
it was a great scene uh it was it was a
sort of it was a it was a flashback it
was about maybe five years before any of
our story takes place and it came after
uh in the script it came after
um Max's chapter and before Madeleine's
chapter
and we tried it and we ran it but it was
like a it was like a pebble in the shoe
it just broke up the I say the flow but
there was something pure about the
timeline or the non-linear timeline and
that actually sort of disrupted it
um so we lost that and it freed it up a
little bit and in a way it was sad
because it sort of understood a bit more
about Max's character and Madeleine's
character but in in a way that I'm never
afraid of leaving those questions out
there you know that you can sort of
leave something like the audience and
then there was another scene one other
scene was in um in Tom's chapter between
Tom and Sandra and uh it was sort of
after the book start after the birthday
party at the bookstores between the two
of them and Sandra is giving
um Tom a present and there was something
that present
and I can't tell you what it is because
it's going to give away it's a plot
spoiler but there was something in that
present that uh again disrupted how you
felt about Sandra and so we had to lose
that scene so only two not bad um I
already got a rap with you I'm just
gonna say uh congrats on the movie uh
and that you don't have to worry about
the opening weekend box office and I
look forward to whatever you're doing
next yeah that's a relief I think that's
a relief we don't have to worry about
that I mean yeah expressly right now I
mean it doesn't feel very fair to be
um judged on that so yeah that is a
relief seriously looking forward to what
you do next oh thank you and thanks for
thanks for saying all the lovely things
you did I appreciate that
not a problem have a great day